hey I've got a challenge for you based
on my next few sentences I want you to
tell me whether you think I'm talking
about Dark Souls or whether you think
I'm talking about Lords of the Fallen
see if you can tell it's a third-person
action RPG where you go around killing
enemies and bosses which gives you
experience you can use to level up your
character and a core mechanic is the
punishment that comes with death because
every time you die you'll drop this
experience and it'll cause you to start
over from the last checkpoint you rested
up and this teaches you to treat your
enemies with caution you know you learn
their weaknesses and you learn their
strengths to ensure that you avoid this
punishment that comes with dying combat
revolves around use of the energy bar
which depletes whenever you perform an
action like attacking or rolling or
blocking and the gear and weapons you
use define how you play giving you
different move sets and more mobility to
tactically take out the barriers in your
path oh and did I mention that every
checkpoint you Resta replenishes your
healing potions and that you need to use
these sparingly to get you through the
level so some of you might have guessed
I am talking about Lords of the Fallen
and Dark Souls Lords of the Fallen is
going to feel very familiar to you as a
Souls fan if I had to describe it in a
sentence I would say that it's a more
heavy-handed version of Dark Souls
clunky Souls and I don't mean that as a
bad thing by heavy-handed I mean that a
it presents the story very directly
rather than with the subtle approach to
storytelling the Dark Souls takes and be
I'd also say that the combat is heavier
and honestly more realistic than any
Souls game out there I think that these
two things are at the core of how Lords
of the Fallen differentiates itself from
the souls series but it definitely still
is similar enough to be judged alongside
it but don't think about it as a Souls
clone I don't think that's a
constructive way to think about it I
prefer to think about the soul series as
genre-defining gods of the Fallen simply
represents the first in a coming trend
of souls like games and that's what
we're doing here with this series I want
us to judge these souls like games from
the souls community's point of view and
I want to make you guys aware of game
that you might want to play because
essentially this is almost like a sequel
to Dark Souls with a few things tweaked
let's talk about gameplay first I was
not exaggerating when I described that
Lords is really similar to souls it
really is it's like they used the souls
series as the foundations of their game
and tweaked it from there but I don't
know about you I'm happy for developers
to build upon the souls mechanics
they're good proven mechanics Lords
controls like a clunky a heavier meteor
Dark Souls the starters' movement is
slower there's this wind up before you
really start running and the majority of
your weapons strike slower - you know
you swing a weapon and it feels heavy
when you smack an enemy it feels like
they seriously took a hit even lighter
weapons like daggers require you to
invest enough time to get your damaging
three-hit combo off the game is balanced
around this slower pace if I had to put
it simply I'd say that you know how
blood-borne is a game that's like Souls
but balanced around a faster pace Lords
is like a slower version of Dark Souls
and just so it's balanced around that
pace it's also easy to say that Lords is
just a slower souls and that's true
because it is but there was something
else about the movement that felt a
little bit different and it took me a
little while to realize it but what I
put it down to is it being more
realistic than Souls you think about
souls enemies often have a small wind up
before their attack and that's
regardless of whatever weapon they're
using now they design it this way so
that you can learn to predict things so
that you can learn to parry and roll and
block and you can basically avoid any
attack no matter what enemy you're
facing in Souls no matter what weapon
they're using you generally expect this
wind up and this attack load seems
different I only go to play against a
few types of enemies in the preview but
their movements were very appropriated
to the weapons they were using and
that's not the same as souls games if
it's a huge enemy in Lords with a huge
ax sure there's this big wind up before
they attack making them very easy to
dodge your parry and you do not want to
get hit by an attack from a big enemy in
this game but you see these smaller
diseased insane enemies with tiny
weapons you should
to expect to wind up for their attacks
these little enemies are sometimes able
to rush you in ways that are completely
impossible to predict at least I felt
like it was and it was only impossible
sometimes but the point I'm trying to
make here is that this highlights a
difference between the two games to me
in Lourdes you're likely to take damage
in souls everything is designed to be
avoidable at first I played Lords of the
Fallen as if I wanted to dodge
everything and avoid all attacks this is
how I play Souls I try to avoid every
single attack and when I came to the
conclusion that some damage is super
hard to avoid in Lords of the Fallen I
wasn't happy I didn't enjoy the game I
thought it was a big oversight on their
part but soon however I put on the heavy
armor and you know what I genuinely
started to enjoy playing this game all
of a sudden the combat started to make
sense Lourdes has this realistic combat
where you're going to get hit so it pays
off to embrace that heavy armor once I
sacrificed my light roll I took 50% less
damage and I barely flinched at attacks
that would have otherwise knocked me
down so yeah
unlike in souls armor is a big deal it's
a heavier game than souls and you've got
a trader like one it's also a more
realistic game I feel so you can
actually judge enemies according to the
weapon they're using so for example like
trading hits with a lighter enemy is
encouraged you can tank their flimsy
hits to deliver this mighty blow of your
own but if you find yourself against
that huge enemy with the huge axe then
you don't want to trade hits with them
you want to avoid their hit so yeah
that's how I feel about the clunkier
combat embrace that heavy armor and you
will have a better time adapting the
importance of the armor and the actual
weightiness of the weapons it all has
this realism that I wish was extended to
the art style this game is all about
those huge shoulder pads and the over
designed weapons with functionally
pointless pointy bits and the enemies
are very diablo 3 ask fantasy creatures
it's not my thing personally i think
there's a bit too much generic fantasy
here but that's just me it might be your
thing and the important thing is that
the art style is consistent which
and that's a great thing back into the
gameplay though these games revolve
around that stamina bar the thing you
use to do every attack your ability to
perform is dictated by it so why not
build a few more mechanics around it
right Lords does this they implement
something called a perfect timing system
where you can save stamina consumed by
your attacks as long as you time them
perfectly mash that button to attack as
quickly as possible and you'll use your
stamina really really inefficiently time
every attack perfectly you'll get the
best value for money the best bang for
your buck you'll be able to attack much
more consistently and do much more
damage over time there were times where
I genuinely made this trade-off between
mashing the button real quick and using
my stamina inefficiently or sometimes I
conserved my stamina for sustained
damage it's a brilliant way to build
upon an existing system and it's
something that I really commend Lords
for another thing they do is implement
something called in overcharged system
where you can hold down our to a little
bit longer
- seriously smack the [ __ ] out of your
enemies as a reward for consuming more
stamina and waiting a little bit longer
it adds this cool element of timing to
attacks and again it's a great way to
add depth to the gameplay and to build
upon a mechanic they've taken a lot of
salt concepts and they've built upon
them and generally they do it really
well take the blood stain and experience
system for example when you kill an
enemy it'll give you experience right
just like in a souls game however in
Lords as you kill multiple enemies
without resting at a checkpoint you'll
build up a multiplier and earn more
experience for every enemy you kill this
is an awesome addition it rewards you
for going out of your way and killing
enemies and exploring new areas it's
also a cool way to add an element of
challenge for those who want it you know
you can skip that next checkpoint to
keep your multiplier going but if you
[ __ ] up and you die then you get sent
further back but that's the risk you
take when you do die from taking too
many risks and going too far or whatever
you'll leave a blood stain behind in
classic souls style however the run back
to your blood stain just got a little
bit more stressful as you run back you
realize oh [ __ ] that
variance I dropped is diminishing
overtime once you arrive at it you'll
notice something else when you're
standing near your blood stain you'll
regain health over time but if you pick
it up this bonus will go away this is a
really cool way of actually benefiting
you in a place that you died previously
and you also have to make a decision do
you want to pick it up straight away or
do you want to use that extra health to
help you in a battle you've found
difficult the way they've added tension
to the blood-stained mechanic is great
and they've made your run back more
stressful and given you a decision to
make once you get there
considering you might have racked up
this huge kill streak this experience
could be seriously important to you
although one thing I do have to mention
is that you're not gonna care too much
about your experience if the game is too
easy and that's something we've yet to
see so far I'd say it feels fairly
similar to Dark Souls 2 levels of
difficulty though difficulty clearly
isn't a priority and we need to see more
of the game for us to judge I mean I
only played like the start of the game
so who knows how difficult it gets right
I found myself dying because I ran out
of healing potions rather than being
overwhelmed by enemies especially on my
tanky character and it was nice having
that suspense back from running out of
healing I hate the fact that you can buy
as many life gems as you want in Dark
Souls 2 and from what I've seen of Lords
light characters are more likely to die
from being overwhelmed because they have
really light armor but heavy characters
are at risk of dying not because they
got overwhelmed but more because you
took too much damage
you know you absorbed too much damage
from attacks and you went through all
your healing that's when you die when
you're out of healing potions and that's
something I really miss from Dark Souls
now because I've only played the preview
which includes two bosses it was hard to
get a feel for the difficulty and the
benefits of leveling up a lot but I'll
get a feel for that when I play the full
game both bosses I fought felt fairly
uncreated but the bosses were good
introductions to the game because the
fights revolved around attacking only
after they'd attacked and they both had
big tower shields so you knew that you
had to attack after you were attacked
and both also had four phases dictated
by their health bars the first boss
sheds his armor and
sheds his defense as the fight goes on
and as the fight goes on he gets more
and more offensive the same rings true
for the second boss as the fight goes on
he starts to summon additional enemies
and and in the fourth phase he starts
summoning two enemies at a time so there
seems to be this trend of them wanting
to make the final phase of the fight are
really intense so you really have to
earn that victory but generally those
two things aren't incredibly creative
but hey that's the first two bosses the
first bosses are never really that
excited but what is exciting is the fact
that every boss has a special way to be
killed if you discover what this unique
way is then the boss will drop a unique
piece of loot that is really really cool
it's just like in Dark Souls 1 how you
could cut off the tail of a boss and
that tail would turn into an item for
you it's an organic way of increasing
the difficulty you're actually putting
the difficulty into the gameplay itself
you're not just artificially increasing
the boss's health or increasing the
bosses damage you know just like you
earn more experience for more risks you
take this adds difficulty in the way we
want and this is the sort of gameplay
design we want carrying over from souls
another thing I really wish that carried
over was the presentation of the story
but I can't have everything
Lords of the Fallen is more direct in
its presentation of the law and the
world it presents it through cutscenes
and little audio Scrolls that you find
plastered throughout the world I
actually really liked this last point
have a listen to this it's great to have
some background to going while you kill
things it is in me and it is changing me
my skull the bones are moving growing it
does not feel like poison in my veins
more like liquid darkness we have seen
with others what happens next
eyesight goes first then follows sanity
brother William brother Peter and I
won't let the disease take us we will
choose death before it chooses us and
while I killed these enemies I head back
given to me on them it's unobtrusive
it's entertaining and I like it if
you're going to present the story more
directly then this is the way to do it
the story also seems fairly optional in
this game you're given the opportunity
to skip it whenever you want man I've
been playing so much destiny that this
is actually a feature to me so the story
is put in your face but at least have
the option of pushing it aside to focus
on the gameplay and honestly all we
really care about is the gameplay right
as souls fans overall I think that the
gameplay shows a lot of promise it
pushes the mechanics of this old series
in directions that I don't think we
would have seen if we had just left from
at the helm I'm at a good place after
this preview and after playing I can
honestly say that I would buy it and I'm
curious to see what the rest of the game
has to offer honestly it just comes at a
really beautiful time Dark Souls Tuesday
LC is just wrapping up and we've also
got a few months until blood-borne so
why not play some Lords of the Fallen in
the meantime this game drops October
28th for us and EU and also on October
31st for my fellow Australians and just
for the Australians I don't quite know
why we get games a little bit later in
this digital age but there you go I
think we're all pretty much used to it
by now I've got a few other games in
mind for this souls like series there's
this little one called
salt and sanctuary coming in 2015
essentially it looks like a little 2d
Dark Souls inspired action platformer
which looks really cute and really cool
so I'll put a preview down in the
description and I'll definitely be
playing that and if I find anything else
that I think is Souls like I'll do a
video on that too I might tweak the
format of these videos based on your
feedback so let me know what you thought
and I'll catch you guys next time thanks
so much for watching
you